hey everybody its Charlie so a bunch of
you requested I do a video for this new
soul jam promo they just released tying
Iron Man to the soul gem it was a lot of
confusion about what they're doing with
a lot of these infinity war promos but
they've already used the prequel story
to give you an idea for where the soul
gem is located or at least where Thanos
is going to find it in the key to taking
it because it's supposed to be in a
separate place like it's not just
sitting around in broad daylight the way
the other gems were you couldn't just
walk up and pick it up and stick it in
the gauntlet so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos there's an
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that's going
on in all these so starting with that
soul gem promo
so everybody saw this artwork and
they're like wait what does this mean
because some of the Avengers are
associated with the gems that they
either possess or the gems that showed
up in their movies with a few exceptions
and I think this is a key to the movie
because I don't think that this is
spoiling anything I think this is just
meant to be a promo with a bit of a hat
tip for the emotional through-line that
will lead to the soul gem so you have
like Captain America with the space gem
you have the power gem with the
guardians of the galaxy I mean you see
spider-man in here too but they will
fight together during the movie the time
gem is with Doctor Strange but you also
see Iron Man with his armor activated
and the hook in the background meaning
this is probably from earlier in the
film you see vision with the mind gem
because he still has the mind gem but
you see Thor with the reality gem so
that's a bit confusing I think what
they're doing here is they're taking
scenes from the trailer in transposing
them on to the scenes of these gems here
so this soul gem moment with Iron Man is
actually taken from trailer footage when
they're on Dan OSes home planet of Titan
because a lot of people have been
recontextualizing the scenes from the
trailer like maybe we've been looking at
the soul gem this whole time without
realizing it in the sly way that Marvel
does misleading things will also just
flat-out showing you everything Thor is
the best example of that like they show
you Thor with both of his eyes during
the Ragnarok trailer when clearly you
were actually looking at him with one
eye it's just that they digitally
altered it so that it wouldn't be a
spoiler because they released these
before the movie came out so if the soul
gem is this big MacGuffin like the last
big gem that we don't know where it is
they don't want to spoil
before we get to the movie but they also
want to show you these cool scenes so
how do they do that they just present
things in a very confusing way so this
planet at the beginning of the trailer
is Thanos home planet they spend a
portion of the film fighting Thanos on
there it's a pretty solid bet that
Thanos has come back there to fight the
Avengers because that's where he's going
to take the soul gem when they're
talking about the soul gem during that
Doctor Strange prequel they're also
looking at a star map like it's in the
stars as if they're looking at a
separate planet the most dangerous gem
of all in part of the reason why the
soul gem is the most dangerous is
because of how its tied to the emotional
through-line of the movie because you
have so much big crazy stuff happening
in the movie but in order to get people
to care about the characters you have to
have a really strong emotional through
line this is where we circle back around
to some Tony Stark Howard Stark
emotional through line back during the
Iron Man films I'm Howard Stark and
everything you'll need for the future
can be found right here
Tony you're too young to understand this
right now so I thought I would put it on
film for you but one day you'll figure
this out
and when you do
you will change the world
what is and always will be my greatest
creation
is you
so think about that Tony Stark
is like the heart of his father he put
his soul into his child he is everything
that he is so fan o also has that same
relationship with his children primarily
Gamora so the key to achieving the soul
gem is the emotional through line
through Gamora Thanos will have to take
the soul gem from Gamora although not in
the way that you would expect so he's
very upset he's still stung by gamora's
betrayal but josh brolin did an
interview talking about Thanos during
the movie and he said that the Thanos
Gamora relationship evolves through the
film his race the people the Titans that
he was unable to save are also tied to
his emotional through-line
so the key to the soul gem is on Titan
because that's the place where his race
went extinct the place that Kevin Feige
says there was a cataclysm that Thanos
saw coming but was unable to prevent so
that's why he wants to assemble the
infinity gems so that he has the power
to change the things that he thinks
needed to be changed bringing it back
around to that Doctor Strange prequel
story when they say that the soul gem is
probably the most dangerous one they
also should say the most gut-wrenching
because what if they knows has to take
the soul gem by killing Gamora and
feeding her soul to the gem itself and
bringing it out of a separate reality
because the whole idea is that the soul
gem exists in a separate reality and
there's a couple of things that you have
to do to unlock it so just flowing from
comic book logic the soul gem wants to
take souls it's sort of vampiric in that
way but it preserves souls after death
it enables life after death
sothe annos can take the soul gem by
giving Gamora soul to it but also
preserve her soul so that at some point
later when they fixed the University
Avengers could always resurrect her we
also found out that we're going to see a
younger version of Thanos during the
movie that will probably be tied to him
thinking about the thing that he wasn't
able to change that destroyed his race
so a lot of you have been asking me if
they're going to retro actively include
Easter eggs from guardians of the galaxy
the way that they did during spider-man
homecoming in Iron Man 2 like a
retroactive Easter Egg whereby a really
cool moment from an earlier film becomes
a much bigger part of Thanos backstory
during infinity war so you probably saw
the in Finn
or preview video that I did I talked a
little bit about the origin of the
Eternals the Eternals are where the
titans race flow from they're incredibly
powerful incredibly advanced so in order
for something to make them go completely
extinct it would have to be incredibly
powerful what did we see during the
guardians of the galaxy film when the
collector was telling us the origin of
the Infinity stones we saw Isan the
searcher one of the Celestials making an
entire planet go extinct in the blink of
an eye with the Power Stone he stones it
seems can only be brandished by things
of extraordinary strength observe these
couriers can use this stone down entire
civilizations like wheat in a field
there's a little pee coming out of me
right now so what if the celestials came
destroyed a noses race he wasn't able to
stop them because they were wielding
Infinity stones and their Celestials
they're incredibly powerful ancient
beings so he wants to assemble the
Infinity Gauntlet to make sure that
things like that never happened again
and that he can balance the universe
like the really twisted thing about
Thanos during the movie is that Josh
Brolin said that he really came to
identify with him sympathize with him
even so even though they have changed a
little bit of his backstory like he's
not in love with death anymore he's more
in love with the idea that he has for
the universe and he cares for his
children in a really twisted way like
Gamora but through this ancient
Cataclysm that killed his race you will
come to sympathize with him even if you
don't completely agree with his methods
you'll understand why he's doing what
he's doing but the whole idea is that
he's still the villain of the film he
wants to kill half of all life in the
universe so let me know in the comments
if the soul gem is gonna be tied to the
emotional through-line paying that off
during the movie and gomorrah's the most
important character to Thanos next to
his home planet of Titan do you think
that he's going to have to take the soul
gem by sacrificing Gamora
but hopefully that explains why they
used this soul gem Iron Man moment from
the fight on the planet Titan for this
promo like the soul gem isn't
necessarily inside Ironman like a lot of
people were wondering about that it's
more that this is all happening on Titan
in the soul gem will flow from that part
of the film leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below and I'll
say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Chad radit message me so
I can get your contact details there was
a new round in this video I'll just name
a new winner when I post new Marvel this
weekend click here for that infinity war
preview that I just posted and click
here to rewatch the full trailer again
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]